thanks boy we've had these clouds around
they blocked our view
of that beautiful lunar eclipse
overnight earlier this morning
but now the sun is up that the moon is
long gone it was behind our western
mountains
by 5 30. we've got sunshine out there
but we still have a fair amount of
clouds
those will be moving out as the day goes
on and we'll have
a lot of sunshine especially for the
afternoon and more heat
we'll have plenty of 90's for afternoon
highs right now a lot of 70's
temperatures still stuck around 80
degrees in green valley 71 at red rock
53 up there at kyle canyon so breezy
south southwest winds today
lots of clouds being pulled up ahead of
this system that's well to the north of
us
over the northern great basin but boy
those clouds were sliding in
all night just north of l.a right up
through southern nevada
and right over into the four corners
area so
really the rest of the state over most
of california up through the pacific
northwest had a great view
of that lunar eclipse last night we've
got it posted on our website and we'll
have
plenty of pictures of it really was
spectacular 94 degrees
early clouds give way to plenty of
sunshine and these hot
mid to upper 90s will be what we'll have
for the rest of the month right through
memorial day weekend so make some cool
plans
have lots of good fresh water for
everybody if you're heading out to the
lake this weekend it looks like some
choppy waters
on saturday so please get those life
jackets ready a hundred degrees for
tuesday to start off june
we're escaping may without triple digits
just barely so get ready for some hotter
days